welcome to this video slightly late
start against sense storm from from
Spain did I play this guy reform no the
Smith mora here should I take it I
normally don't take it okay let's do it
I really have some mom I have some
respect against this is opening i think
it's it's so quite quite dangerous
really ok Knight f6 and se5 so not that
one Bishop g4 runs into night into a
bishop of seven so i can go e six i can
go ecigs now ok let's do a six and now
Knight f6 is possible as far as I know
so if I've I can I can capture
hmm what about isn't Bishop g4 now a
good move design I thought he needs to
react to that to this Bishop g4 idea I
really have forgotten how how exactly
but there is this 95 it's a bit slow
it's a bit slow though okay 95 he can
even take so I must be must be cautious
95 95 which should be to Bishop f7
checkmate it's a bit a bit embarrassing
okay I probably go here Queen takes I
have 95 so this wasn't great so this was
basically forced now okay he has f45 the
sum needs to be addressed okay I cannot
go without his 6cm land I don't think
that g6 fits so well into this better e
6 Bishop e7 yeah yeah this is absolutely
necessary otherwise White has no play at
all so this should be 70 plus 5 I wonder
if maybe Queen a5 as a possibility Queen
a5 is covering against a five so i can
just take it and I I threaten or intend
to swing it over to h5 yeah I like that
next position is still very very very
sound
I don't have any substantial weaknesses
b6 slide square weakness ok hmm yeah I
must admit that that I had
underestimated that who I forgot that he
sixes immediately hanging to be honest
well that's not that's not so nice
yeah if I go f15 if i go i 5 i'm giving
up the d5 square but i get d for entry
turn maybe i should do it jump I don't
know no stairs some guy taking looks
somewhat somewhat weird and they don't
see any way how i can let him take ok i
probably must play that and this
probably means that Queen a5 wasn't
great maybe yeah again and again it's a
difficult game that we chose to play
young the resource account to play here
is 90 form it's the main problem
actually of the the moral gambit the
Smith moral gambit that's them the
square weakness on deform exist in fact
now 94 is a move and move that it's not
so easy to meet actually why was he
going after that Queen III night see to
enter Knight f3 is also in the end up
position not sure 93 93 23 night see to
winning the CM champ but where exactly
as the compensation okay I probably
should do that
ok and here is he threatening this
discovery not probably
b5 is going to take with the night even
94 maybe wasn't really timed so well now
that I think of it
night beehive is a threat even here I
probably should move the Queen but i'm
not sure where I go queena all the way
back to da da hiscott Bishop e3 and 94
was stupid evil play Bishop e3 anyway
and it's not clear what this is this is
doing I mean if this is helping me in
any in any way
what I'm wondering is actually if night
be five if I can sacrifice the Queen
somehow like a bee Bishop f5 and take on
c4 but you can just take on c4 am I
don't have a good square for this for
the Queen rellium
it's always this 92 nonsense or Bishop
e3 okay let's move the Queen away from
them it's prob maybe not a good spy
don't I don't know where to go that was
stupid 94 was exceptionally stupid I
could instead I could have just
continued to develop and reserve this
move for for some better time yeah he
just has the much better development
Jim
yeah it's not nice it's not nice at all
yeah you will just regain it on the form
yeah but I don't really don't really
know if I've got something better than
that
you
yeah white can think about maybe it's a
question you could also try to play
night d hi first or 9292 might be an
option as well but then I can take on
you two actually okay not not so great
ninety-five though this is a possibility
but takes Bishop takes bishop f6 helps
me so it'd be just you should just take
it on d4 I mean yeah so now Queen trade
or not yeah it's not a very attractive
position with the Queen's right hurry
and T I mean at least his King is
somewhat weakened so Queen takes what am
i doing then
yeah I take on b2 is going to play rook
be one Queen a 3d Brooke v7 okay some
entirely different what was wrong about
24 I don't get it this just just good
now I mean what is he doing after Quincy
6 i'm detecting this and I'm threatening
b5 and you fall on top of all of that
maybe he can play Queen D for tween a
for Bishop f7 and queen d for b5 Bishop
b3 because taking on a for Bishop a four
wins the Queen looks completely bonkers
maybe it's still possible may I plate
that so b5 is going to play Bishop b3 am
amazing
so somehow it feels that I should have a
good move here but I don't I fail to see
it it looks some suspicious yeah I came
I don't really I don't really know where
firm B fibers help Amy
ok
yeah 95 maybe the Sun establishes a very
very strong bishop on d5 I need to take
it Bishop g5 very strong piece on d5 but
my bishop will come to f6 and there's no
dummy as well
I guess I need to take it him I fatigue
if Roy he's got rookie one simply at the
end and that's not turn up nice I Bishop
g5 though
well Janice is getting maybe he had 95
okay rookie one Bishop g5 that's an
important resource I probably have not
seen that but it's still not clear at
all the bishop on c4 in the nine only
six are quite um quite annoying pieces
ja Knight to f6 on c5 it's not stable at
all and they have maybe Bishop f4 to e5
this would be a very nice if he or some
rookie 7 maybe yeah maybe rookie salmon
Wow
okay cannot take because he's seven
hangs
95 95 pursuit of the c7 a he needs to
move the bishop somewhere then I need to
reconsider what what am I do are going
to do here with b7 shamrock be a 26
exceptionally passive really
maybe I need to play something like 94
94 Brooke be 795 and then take on b3 and
then deform establishing this pass on a
know B 8 is just so passive cannot
cannot really believe in that move ok
yeah this might involve giving a booth
queenside points yeah but passive play
does not to really help him
after rook move I'm going to capture and
go deform
yeah not easy at all the serm this game
okay this some at some point in not
taking no I guess it isn't no need to do
that now no d5 is hanging so this needs
to needs to be pushed okay interesting
if he takes a six now I play rook d6 and
this is some the sea plate quickly isn't
this a nasty pin I'm intending to go
Bishop the ATM or rugby aids but rugby 8
yeah also beard but Bishop dietas some
this is already quite tricky and I'm not
with taken he needs to play I exactly
this one and next move oopsie form and
sorry night c4d three nights you form
and he's stopping it just in time
anyway and now you can also go to d4 or
here and this runs right into 93 yeah
but probably still better Rock v5 is
also useful move to have available went
down to two minutes only saw that now
need to be quick and I've got a week
back ranked this i urgently need to
address probably h5 at some point
it's so difficult I only have this very
little time available because rook g6 I
take it play rock the aid yeah ik i
suspect it's about equal
yeah taking be three
trying to simplify rookie eight maybe or
get rid of the the pawn yeah i hope i
hope to have chances to get them to get
their pawn check
I can maybe play of six still probably a
wrong map f6 maybe i can go g5 and then
h5 and approach with the King their
salts not some play left in this
position it's not completely dead but I
wonder he must play of 6 and no he
doesn't check just lets me take him
check now this should be a winner
brilliant the B porn is not sewing them
I can this is three points so a bit bit
much I came know this one but what do we
have here 109 ok
yeah the pawn on its own is not so
dangerous check it's more more weakness
really and I can push with f6 center and
g5 hi morning there it's it's plenty of
time one minute is is quite good check
you have two connected to passers check
again the king is going to support the
pawns
white resins gap that was a very tricky
game I think I made out of the opening I
made some some pretty bad decisions okay
what's starting here I mean this should
be really good for black I mean cannot
believe in that but now around here yeah
maybe maybe I'm overestimating things f5
is a plan i mean it's it's evident it's
a plan yeah this is probably not so
great relief I am completely a
underestimated f5 and wide know as a
really substantial compensation for the
pawn even that I mean it looked a bit
weird but it wasn't so terrible computer
wants to do this though yeah this is
just an exceptionally strong piece it
wants to play and along these lines with
an excellent compensation really am
fantastic Bishop and there's this this
coming tell that very good for wine yeah
this I don't know probably bad timing 94
and here yeah yeah night a four is a
really strange news but I failed to
refute it I went here which is just not
good you can take on me for I must blow
here it seems yeah yeah this is good
yeah probably this is a big threat
gather the computer says blacks winning
here I didn't consider it I only after I
played it recognized that you can really
cut capture and then okay I cannot go
here check
so yeah what else is down yeah t I just
expected 95 it should be somewhat better
for weidman fantastic piece mine is
getting better on f6 as well but still
this is what he played yeah i know i can
take on your phone i mean i don't know i
don't sorry i'm not sure that you really
should play now I should play wookie one
it's not helping much really we should
be five yeah this is maybe better this
is a line that the engine is giving with
the quality may be why it's still very
active no this does not really help her
guess still yeah I needed to do that the
idea here you can maybe search for
improvements I don't know I like the
idea to to get activity here but maybe
there are other ways to play and now I
know it took it here this was
fascinating that he got into the self
pen this was necessary and now this here
the computer wants to trade and play
work 2-8 they would be 8 like this and
then we'll be eight and which
okay okay okay i'm covering d8 this is
what i forgot i just thought he goes
here and i cannot take but I'm can I
have the maid covered he owned d 8
because of the bishop came yeah then
this is of course better for black but
what about this down okay very weak bone
structure but is it yeah it is a bit
better for black but is it a win
difficult 0.7 the computer evaluation
okay we had we had this end game check
ciao this probably should be a draw with
best play but I'm going to yeah he gave
me the spawn a must-play f6 I don't
understand why not have six and here i
can i can win a pawn like that but this
is this is just nothing I don't think
that this is a really helping me much
this doubled porn I guess I probably
after f6 sorry after f6 I would have
played g5 I guess with this idea
approaching with the King and tried to
win it yeah this um this is just lost
this end game which was shown in the
game I think quite convincingly alright
thanks for watching